[Music]
are you ready to have another baby
that's kylie jenner and travis scott
giving a glimpse of life before
welcoming their son
and now that the little guy is here a
source is telling e.t how the couple's
relationship has changed
i love it
last month kai and trev welcomed their
second child together making their
four-year-old daughter stormi a big
sister the source explains that the pair
is getting used to having two little
kids and it's a day by day process but
overall they are doing great
they were prepared as they could be for
this and both of them wanted it more
than anything having two kids made a big
difference for them as parents and in
their own relationship in a positive way
i'm obsessed with it on monday the duo
dropped this 10-minute video documenting
kylie's pregnancy journey which includes
some seriously precious family moments
[Music]
the kids bring such joy you know and it
makes everything worth it and then when
your kids your babies have babies it's
magic our source says stormy loves her
new role and she couldn't take more
pride in it seeing that also makes kylie
and travis so proud and happy we're just
so excited that stormy is going to be a
big sister
[Applause]
[Music]
but when it comes to life after baby it
hasn't exactly been smooth sailing
earlier this month the beauty mogul
shared this update about the struggles
getting back into shape
this experience for me personally has
been a little harder than with my
daughter
it's not easy mentally
physically
spiritually
it's just
crazy i think we can look on the
internet and
you know for other moms going through
right now
um
we can go on the internet and it might
look a lot easier for other people and
like put the pressure on us but it
hasn't been easy for me
it's been hard
and i just wanted to say that so i
didn't even think i'd make it to this
workout today
but i'm here and i'm feeling better
so
you got this
and when things get tough kylie's
leaning on her man for support
our source says the rapper is a
dedicated dad and very protective of
their family it's a quality that kylie
and the rest of the kardashians and
jenners absolutely adore about him
he makes sure to show kylie and their
little ones how loved they are in many
ways they are doing well as a couple
since welcoming their son
[Music]
you